[Music]  there is some good news to start uh off  the show uh in yemen i haven't heard  about this a u.s drone strike has killed  al qaeda's number two leader the sixth  second in command the u.s has killed  so this is this is one area where obama  can say he definitely is creating jobs  do you know what i'm saying  they're they're forget about it  they're temporary jobs right right  that no one should want  they always in their in their staffing  they always say there's room for growth  [Laughter]  oh they need another number two let's go  over the weekend mitt romney made an  appearance at a nascar race in virginia  yeah  there was an awkward moment when he  asked a nascar driver why he didn't just  hire a chauffeur  so  he didn't  you know the backseat's very  uncomfortable  [Laughter]  mitt romney is not backing down